and we are live welcome to another
episode of iron Lord oh wait wrong show
what's going on you
guys welcome to the add show where we
talk about the
past present and future of gaming I got
my co-host with me D gy what's going on
D yeah what's up adct it's a lot to talk
about man what's what's going on man I
heard you uh you were being hunted
by uh certain types of people out there
in these Twitter streets oh no I'm being
chased down I'm being chased through the
streets uh they're not fing me right now
they they're not fing me they feel like
I have what's funny is the place Xbox
people came at me last week and now the
PlayStation people are at me this week
and it's just like look like I get it
tomorrow I'm gonna make a video on the
uh the the the event that we had today
you know it's not going to be mad
negative but I'm gonna have some
critiques and you know I'm sure some of
the Xbox people go like that uh but it
is what it is because I'mma do it anyway
it's just like look like and then I
had I had someone that came to uh that
that ComEd and was like well you know
maybe it's because the thumbnail is just
mad negative no the thumbnail was about
Spider-Man being broken well not broken
I think that's a strong word high bugs
High bugs right and that's what the
video is about the video wasn't no
review it wasn't no
Impressions so it's just like what in
that case you're trying to have me do a
toxic
positivity and it's like no that's not
what the video was about the video was
about the fact that I personally feel
like the game delivered an unacceptable
point and I even think think that it's
not there's a difference between being
broken Dart and and being unplayable
would you not agree absolutely
Spider-Man's playable because of the
checkpoint system they have implemented
in this game it's playable but I would
you know if you don't want to deal with
none of that nonsense I would would not
look at you sideways if you was like
I'mma wait for you know
set yeah I started playing it um
yesterday H what what's your early
impressions well so far it's pretty cool
I had the uh Sam fight because I'm still
you know I just started playing it I I
did that boss fight and that's it so so
I haven't run into any bugs
yet but yeah I mean that part was pretty
cool yeah it's just like look you know
people didn't like my you know my stance
when it come to the Superman stuff La
superhero stuff last week and now I will
say the PlayStation people have been on
my ass more you know uh they don't like
my thumbnail you know I'll show you guys
my thumbnail for those of you that
didn't see it let me let me show show my
screen you know people people definitely
ain't feeling this thumbnail and I get
it but they need to realize we don't
care like see here's my thumbnail guys
you know this this is what it looks like
on my end as my thumbnail I think that's
a good thumbnail man why they hating man
they hating because it doesn't fit their
narrative they didn't have an issue and
what's funny is I got like you know this
thumbnail
uh I got all these thumbnail I make a
lot of videos I I you don't really know
it until I like look at my thumbnails
but I make a lot of
videos you see what's funny is like they
didn't
mind the videos where I'm like
criticizing Xbox you know when I say I
think they're you know lacking in in the
in the in the Japanese Department you
know I think they need to do better on
their shows what's funny is a lot of
things I've criticized Xbox on they've
improved so I don't know man I don't
know well you know how it is adct um see
like when I have problems
with guys you know that's that go out
there and say something like you know I
totally disagree with the superhero
Thing mostly my like my beef was mostly
bro they they are in the best position
they have ever been come on man this is
not the time to be complaining about
something else not you know what I'm
saying so like when I like I got a toour
with d batch he was like come on man you
know some of the stuff that he was
saying I was like bro you can't yeah
people said he I don't like they said
he's G to make a video on me I don't
know if like about you yeah because I
made that video you know how it is
though people be like dragging the truth
you know maybe he commented on my video
or something and you know he he he's not
going to make a video I mean I think he
would have made one by now but it's like
even if he does it's like look it's my
opinion just like whatever your opinion
is on me that's your opinion
yeah I mean listen that's the community
we're in you know people are going to
agree with us people are going to
disagree with us and that's it man
that's it that's just how it is it feels
like they low-key want like Echo
Chambers and it's like it's like look me
and dart might have different opinions
but the end of the road is the same we
want a better Xbox
ecosystem and what's funny is like the
PlayStation a lot of these PlayStation
they don't want a better Xbox ecosystem
no they want maintain their stuff so all
right so let me someone did bring up a
uh okay right here someone said kind of
new to this channel is this Channel
owned by Collins Last Stand Media or is
it uh is it's it's its own thing U you
know this channel is the the channel for
IL I just you know have it on this
channel I have my show on this channel
but pretty much this channel you know we
we talk about a lot this adct show is a
multi podcast Channel we talk about
everything uh but we are definitely
favorite the the green we definitely
favorite the green so yeah that that
answers your question for you um let's
let's get into let's get into the news
you know we we got some stuff to talk
about first off I want to talk about the
Spider-Man two bugs you know because um
I got a lot of hate for this this what
my video is about and obviously you know
if I can upset some people that was
upset already I'mma do it because they
were coming at me
hardcoree so obviously you said you know
you're not too far into the game so you
can't really speak a whole lot about the
about the bugs but you know just what
you've seen on Twitter that doesn't
involve still shots because I think
still shots is easy
to it's easy to trick you know 100%
besides those I want I'm talking
strictly about in motion glitches what
have you seen I've seen a ton bro I mean
we've seen several videos of people that
was live
streaming and a glitch will happen you
know I don't know if you saw fanga video
but he had a concoction of a like a like
a compilation of different streamers or
different bugs I had a few in my latest
video um so yeah this is a real thing
but let me say this ad I do want to say
this all games have bugs right some
obviously have more than
others so when we point out these bugs
you know like there's bugs in Starfield
there's bugs in any game you know 100%
so it's like us Xbox fans we're making
fun of these guys because they did it to
us that's that's how I I can't speak for
all Xbox dudes but that's what I feel
bro we're making fun because they did it
to us and we still trying to justify the
90 that it got like the 91 okay it's a
great game but damn I mean why do bugs
affect some games and some games it
doesn't now I know they said the
patch the uh the the like the launch day
patch is what caused the bugs damn
that's unfortunate if that's what really
happened if the how did you address that
I don't know bro I like as a reviewer I
don't I didn't get a code for Spider-Man
2 but I don't know how I would
address going out recommending a game to
someone and then right afterwards the
one patch just messes the whole game up
I'm kind of I'm kind of curious how that
even happened did they like not test it
like it's like what the day when patch
is supposed to fix things how did it
mess things up
more yeah I mean that makes no sense to
me I mean we've seen patches that might
have had you know added some type of
issues to the game but I've never seen a
patch that added this many bugs because
there's even some hardcore uh uh
PlayStation guys being honest like yo
man this game is a buggy mess um I'm
it's still a good game of course you
know I'm not saying it's a bad game I
don't think nobody is saying it's a bad
game um but you know let's be real
here from what we've seen like I'm only
about 30 minutes into the game so I
haven't seen any bugs yet but what from
we've seen from live streamers from
Clips even PlayStation guys have been
posting Clips like yo what is this not
the hardcore ponies but some guys that's
more honest it is what it is man I mean
we can't sit here and say the game isn't
buggy do you think reviewers are lying
that that it was or do you think that
they're they're not telling the truth on
that because they're scared to get
blacklisted by PlayStation or do you
think they're being genuine that there
was no issues because ACG did cosign
that there was no issues like very very
few issues I I I would use the term for
so I trust him uh I do feel like even if
that even if sod held a gun to his fa
head it was like yo if you say they they
there bugs in this game we we we we
ending our relationship with you ACG
would still tell people so like I I I
still I trust him right uh but it's just
like you know King said it's like they
looked at ACG and they're like we have
an out
like it's like it's like they they
jumped out in front of it and it was
like it didn't feel coordinated but it
did feel like people were tweeting that
around the same side same
time you know you just as a great
question bro you asked a great question
do you think some of the guys are fake
and I
mean like you said ACG seems to be a
trustworthy guy so I would say no um but
I think um it's where some of the issues
come is what how how like how does this
happen Insomniac is a great developer
quality
developer how did this happen like how
did a patch cause this many issues did
did you see that they
are um all the people that haven't
reviewed the game yet no I didn't yeah
there's still a
bunch not like a like an absurd amount
but there's still
people that uh haven't reviewed the game
so let me
let me scroll to it I know that yeah
there there's people you have to go to
the bottom to see it yeah so let me you
could see what I share right on your
side oh yeah all right let me share
this all right so here is can you see
this yes sir so here is
the polygon oh wow polygon the verse
Kotaku the AV Club joh bomb damn they
damn none of these people have revealed
it that's that's weird and I think these
people are just people that that are
verified they have a code you know
because they they came and gave some
type of like sentence like you know this
dude gave it a 70 what I've noticed is
you're
seeing huge jumps between people that
got the game
before and people got the game after
like that's the reason like these
companies haven't reviewed the game yet
because they're playing it now and I'm
curious if they're just they're just
taking a little bit of time to play
because it's so long
or if they they just they they got the
code after it came out but even if they
got after it came out man it's not like
it's a long game like Starfield but you
you got to keep it's not just reviewing
the game okay like the these people got
got to they got to ride it up they got
editors like this is a little bit of a
process now when it comes to someone
like me I could just do a review pop it
out there put some gameplay in it edit
it really nice pop it out there they got
to go through an editor uh an editor got
okay then they got go through the
process of videoing like there is a
little bit of a process when it comes to
what they're doing on their end so I'm
kind of curious on that and you know we
gota like I said sometimes media very
you know they they're very entitled so
it's just like you know when they review
these games at these developers did not
get a review code they're already
blacklisted from PlayStation to some
degree wow so what does that mean
they're playing you can argue a a way
buggier game than than than the review
play right right so it's just like it's
gonna be interesting to see
if this 90 stays a
90 I kind of expect it to go down a
point or maybe even two depending on how
bad right their experience is playing
with all these bugs and it's like I said
you know I'm not going to say any of
these companies would would review bom a
game to make a statement because they
didn't get a review code but sometimes
like I said ain't nothing wor ain't
nothing more entitled than than a
prominent review Outlet not getting a
review code
right interesting stuff right there man
you know it is what it is at this point
I don't really care what it reviews as
you know uh I think it's a fantastic
game it definitely is a 90 Plus game if
it's working correctly but because there
is a lot of a lot of issues I'm kind of
curious where it's going to sit at like
you know I'm kind of curious if it's
going to go down or up I I would be very
surprised if it went up uh I would be
very surprised at this point hey man let
me say this before you get to the super
chats uh because the people in the chat
has been bringing it up but I totally
forgot that um some of the reason I got
into it with another YouTube is because
they saying people was forcing
bugs and and I saw like another comment
people said another podcast was saying
people was forcing bugs and that's what
really pissed me off let's let's talk
about that ideal in general
mhm if you can force bugs to this degree
right the game's already broken 100% you
know that was some of the reasons I was
upset come on people ain't forcing bugs
bro it's just like they're like oh it's
scripted so you go off a script and the
game just breaks yeah like if you notice
when you play a mission in in Spider-Man
if you go out of the boundaries it will
say go back to this area you're leaving
the mission area that is how they
enforce you staying in a certain area
right they didn't do that with the bike
the bike has fallen through
multiple multiple for forms of the
ground so that's not it like people are
just I don't understand why so many
people are defending this I even still
recommended it I saido if you can get
through all all these issues because to
me it's like there's gamebreaking bugs
but the checkpoint system makes it a lot
more forgiving I was like if you're
willing to deal with that then I would
say it but if you know if you want to
wait I wouldn't blame you but it's just
like I just I do feel like there are
Xbox and Playstation
people that every time one of these
games like Starfield or Spider-Man comes
out they gotta speak out because they
want to feel like they're
neutral like they that they're willing
to attack stuff they see and it's just
like it's like dude we get it like you
you you want PlayStation fans following
you like we get it you know that's why I
I understand that to a point because
people will call me like an Xbox Fanboy
or something and you know I embrace it
ad of course you know that see like me
and you are different because I because
I do want to make PlayStation content uh
you know I don't make a lot of it but I
don't want to be seen as someone that
just hates PlayStation for no reason if
you look at all my videos I do keep it
in the middle to a to a degree sure I
might joke around because it's funny and
because uh Playstation people at my
throat for years but to a point I do try
to keep it realistic in the middle so I
tried to because I feel like
people they get the word fan and Fanboy
mixed up and you know I don't want to be
known as the people spoiling
Spider-Man um you know I want to be
known as the person that it's like
because I like reviews I love reviews so
it's like if I'm automatically deem that
and I can't I can't make reviews cuz
people are going to automatically assume
that I'm corrupted oh why would we watch
a Last of Us Part three review from
addict because he's just gonna he's just
gonna he he's just gonna [__] on the
game you know what I'm saying so yeah
it's just like it's crazy man people be
moving around in these streets I don't
know why they do it but they be doing it
yeah it's like with me you know what
expect from me so that's why I'm like
transparency is the key like you said
some people try to play neutral will try
to appease to everybody you can't you
can't appease to everybody see I've been
very I've been very clear it's like look
my preferred platform is Xbox and what's
funny is like it's it's like I told
people when it come to the people
spoiling Starfield people want to act
like that didn't happen like people
wasn't spoiling Starfield it's like
where did you what did you think the
Xbox TR hards were gonna do they know
the hate campaign about Starfield bro
for months and you know what's funny you
can spoil SP Spiderman way easier than
you could spoil Starfield and it's like
where did you think these people are
going I'm not I'm not coing their
behavior but sometimes when what you
throw out comes back it's stronger and
it hits you in the damn
face and it's just like you know if both
sides would put arms down there won't be
no issue but the problem is is now
because of this Spider-Man thing because
of what three or four people did on
Twitter spoiling Spider-Man and they
were very good DT they were good I had
it spoiled to me and they put it in a
Starfield video oh wow so I was look I
clicked on a Starfield video because it
it it looked like it was something I
cared about and then bam spoiler and I'm
like I could like you know how your mind
your brain will read something before
your mind understands where what you're
reading so I already read the whole
sentence right and then after that I was
like Ah that's a WAP and I kind of like
I kind of try to like tell told myself I
didn't see it I didn't see that I I read
it wrong like no I was saying adct Halo
infinite I got three different
DMS people DM me spoiling uh Halo
infinite I quickly deleted two of them
and but one of them I accidentally read
a little bit I said oh he's trying to
spoil Halo infinite so this has been
going on for a while man but that's the
thing but you know like I hate the
people that go online if you're spoiling
Spider-Man you're just a a-hole which
they probably are but you didn't say
that same thing with
Starfield I mean some people did but
some people didn't so you know it it is
what it is man you know I went out and I
just said yo this ain't cool because if
you're spoiling Spider-Man you're
spoiling me too yeah there was some
clater all damage man people like me
that didn't spoil Starfield I got hit
with that Spirit Bomb just like the dude
right next to
me it's just like you know there's more
creative ways to get back at people you
should create a YouTube channel Channel
get traction and talk [__] that's what
you should do that's what you should do
you know don't don't go on and just
start spoiling stuff on Twitter uh
because it's just like you don't need to
there's plenty of other ways to get
other people's
skin all right so let's get these super
chats we got $5 Super Chat from the
angry therapist the game needed more
time to cook I think son was like we
have to put something out and they
forced this game out I would agree to to
degree I'm kind of curious how
some want you go back and play this game
without the day one patch on disc and
see what happens but the but the disc
wasn't installing was no uh we got
Raiden Blade with the member chat been a
member for 31 month uh months dirt dark
Wonderman I hate you my girls think
you're the real dark chocolate love you
bro ho yeah and the DMS the the DRM PS5
slim remember Xbox One PS4 DRM actually
we can talk about that uh yeah let's
talk about that after after we read
these super chats $20 Super Chat from pH
two uh Brooklyn New York yep people are
gonna go even harder on Xbox game with
bugs reviews Impressions after this back
and forth the new Xbox game G to get hit
hard hate to break it to your face
they're going to go hard on Xbox game
regardless this what happened
regardless got a $2 Super Chat from you
know I got
so you indeed good or you still or you
still some I ain't saying that part but
yeah he's he's talking about cuz when me
and dbass got into it he said you need
some you know come on man marry
man stop it I was like come on with
these childish insults bro come on man
it's Like We Grown yeah come why is that
the number one assault that that people
use you don't get no ass that's like the
number one thing that they love to say
is I won't you go out and touch grass
it's like dude so some like what's funny
is like you look at people like Cognito
Cognito built like like it's like people
be acting like
everyone besides me because I I'm
definitely I need to hit the gym a
little more I ain't GNA sit here and lie
to you guys like
that it's just like dude stop it we just
enjoy the game and it's like when you
lose an argument it's the first thing
you have to think of is yo let's let's
throw let's throw that you don't have a
life
card it's like that ain't gonna work on
me because guess what I know I don't got
a life so it's like what you gonna say
that I don't already know oh man yeah so
it's you know it's all crazy stupid to
me all right so let's talk about the
PlayStation
DRM which is insane
um I'm kind of curious what your opinion
on to this so go ahead and you might be
disappointed in my opinion
bro the Xbox homies you might be
disappointed in my opinion you don't
care I don't
care I don't give a d bro I don't even
that's not even a talking point to me
you know I like to grab ammunition for
the console war and just now this is
just I didn't even make a video about
that I I don't give a damn bro you know
for me personally I just don't care I I
don't I don't we don't care what's that
dude in in the sports that does that we
don't care Stephen A Smith let me tell
you something we don't care that's how I
hear right now I just don't care bro I
you know it's all my Xbox homies the r
and Blade with the Super Chat y'all the
homies but that's just not anything I I
just don't care it comes down to it it's
like look you
know at the end of the day Sony going to
protect their brand if people can just
go out there and buy a third party one
for a fraction of the price because this
thing is mad expensive for what they're
offering they're going to do that uh you
know I I don't blame them for trying to
make sure no you buying our stuff uh you
know they shouldn't they should give you
the option but then to be honest you
know it's hard to tell how this was
thrown together so maybe it only works
with that this drive to the degree they
needed to you know imagine like a
PlayStation just sitting down with the
side off and it's just like wire and
there's
like it's just like I understand I do I
understand I'm not g to sit here and try
to act like they shouldn't be doing this
they should give you the option but when
you when you're dealing with a company
that makes Hardware first off when
you're dealing with PlayStation because
clearly the only thing they care about
is they about the payers they they they
want your pennies your dollars they want
your kids trust fund accounts they want
your kids college accounts they want it
all they want all that you know they
don't care about your kids going to
school they're like you know give them a
PlayStation 5 that'll be fine like it's
just it's insane man and they should
give you the option but at the end of
the day are we gonna are we gonna
complain about see I'm All Digital so
none of this matters to me right that's
kind of where I'm at bro it just it just
doesn't matter you know when Xbox tried
to do it in
2013 the media went crazy about it but
honestly guys it's it's 10 years later
the world is in a different place
DRM is funny because of the hypocrisy
it's funny but me personally there's so
many other things that's going wrong
with PlayStation I rather talk about
than this that's just me you know I know
we tried to use it for for for some for
some
trash we're gonna get to it but there is
way more yeah there's way more stuff
rather talk
about that that as big as that does
sound C
that is pretty big as big as that
is we're gonna talk about pretty much
his equivalent to like getting hit with
a spe bomb straight in the face like
right now we just talking about you know
Goku doing a an instant transportation
and just punching you you know it might
might give you a bloody nose but you
know but it what we about to talk about
is the hay maker man it's that father
and on Kamehameha wave man it's that
spear bomb super spear bomb to the face
oh man yeah we about to get into that so
there was it's like I said you know it
wasn't really a whole lot to talk about
when it comes of that but let's talk
about this Xbox stuff
um there has been a report that
apparently they're changing how
Executives make money when it comes to
finances did you see that yeah so
apparently they're not doing it solely
off of Game Pass anymore it's to my
knowled to to my understanding it's more
of a general thing like the whole brand
growing they get paid yeah so uh what do
do you feel that that
is that that's an issue do you feel like
that shows that game pass is failing
like what's your opinions on that no we
can't say Game Pass is failing and then
they say
Starfield had the um like caus the
biggest one day subscribers to Game Pass
I mean no no no man I just think you
know sometimes they change the way they
they they do metrics I mean I no I don't
think Game Pass is definitely not
failing I think Game Pass is doing fine
um because they're constantly investing
in Game Pass and Microsoft has a history
of know maybe letting stuff go but no
they're doing fine man yeah um I
actually happy they did this because I
did feel like the company was swaying
way to Too Much towards Game Pass like I
always felt like the ecosystem needs to
be
a the ecosystem itself needs to be the
the body and Game Pass is just an arm
you know what I'm saying like I want
game pass to be a tool that Xbox uses to
compete I don't want it to be the
identity of Xbox and I felt like they
were going more towards the Game Pass
bag than anything
else I agree with that that was a great
great analogy I like that yeah I want
you know I don't mind the Game Pass bags
but I think you know the first party
unique third party and and second party
those make more sense but I didn't like
the fact that they weren't going for
marketing if this because they couldn't
get Game Pass in it I didn't like the
fact that they weren't trying to get
timed exclusives because they couldn't
get it in Game Pass it's like look Game
Pass is a huge essential tool that
Microsoft can use to compete but it
cannot be the end all be all because I
felt like they were they they were
stabbing themselves in the back trying
to make that and you know how I know
that's where we're going because if you
last couple events the first like four
years of game pass's
existence every event we saw from them
was Game Pass is doing this game pass to
doing that every game has Game Pass you
get Game Pass you get Game Pass like
yeah but now Game Pass is is is is
present every event but that last event
we just did that was a a a
partnered showcase which we're about to
talk about that too and guess what like
one game was Game
Pass I agree with that I agree me it's
more important to build a brand that is
friendly with everything and not just
the people that's willing to put their
game in Game Pass I agree with that it
seemed like um their
focus was mostly well was like was 100%
Game Pass and because of that sometimes
the content they showed was focused on
Game Pass meaning they probably didn't
show some things or some third party
deals that wasn't that wasn't part of
Game Pass but they wanted to say say at
the end of the show or at the beginning
of the show everything we're showing
here is in Game Pass so um I agree with
that but at the same time like M just
put in there content and services was
up and I'm pretty sure Game Pass is a
part of that right so yeah let me ask
you a question obviously they could
never get rid of game pass because it
would be a PR nightmare I personally
feel like they'd be fine they' get a Hu
hit with a huge PR but if they start
dropping good games people would just
completely ignore that [__] uh because
Gamers go where the games are it doesn't
matter what it
isend if Nintendo Wii uu could survive
and make a switch and the PS3 could
survive and make a PS4 and be successful
on both of those fronts with the
horrible PR that both of those
individual products are in they could
easily go that way are they most likely
not but I think as long as you have the
good games people will go wherever you
are if they could literally remove Game
Pass without bad backlash do you think
they
would um no no I think Game Pass is good
for them I think it's sustainable and I
think it's the future um what what
they're
doing is great if Game Pass was still at
two million okay I got a perfect example
I don't know if you watch WWE but they
had something called the WWE Network
right they put all of their
pay-per-views you know their big shows
on there they had a bunch of good great
content on there but eventually they had
to sign a deal with
peacock and peacock instantly had
already had like 25 million subscribers
and the reason they did that because WWE
Network wasn't growing they were stuck
at 1.5 million subscribers for like two
to three straight years they weren't
growing so they had to do something else
Xbox game excuse me is at what we don't
know but we can assume 25 uh I would say
between 25 and 30 right I would say it's
in the 30s by now stara most likely put
it in the 30s yes so he still growing
just like with the YouTube channel man
if you're stuck at 200
subscribers for two three years maybe
you should look in the mirror and say
what am I doing wrong but if you're
growing you can you can get 30 Subs a
month but you're still growing you're
going to continue to do what you're
doing so Xbox game pass is still growing
is it growing as fast as they want I
don't know maybe maybe not but I think
it's it's it's the future man just you
know that's an advantage they have and
if you look at something like Netflix
how long did it take Netflix to get
where they are now because I remember
Netflix for a while was four million and
then eventually five million it took
them a while so Xbox game pass is going
to be great and that's the reason
they've invested so much because their
service is going to be bro it it's
already amazing it's going to be even
more incredible once ABK stuff is in is
in there man so yeah and I think for the
most part you know they're going to
really grow and I think I don't think
that they've went away from Game Pass as
a focus but I think they're starting to
see more stuff on equal grounds you know
because because of stuff like Call of
Duty you know they can't really do
nothing with uh Call of Duty right now
but I I do think they're starting to
look more into console sales because
don't get a twisted when you start
seeing Xbox at the end of every Call of
Duty game
people don't realize you know I guess
you can you know it could be pure you
know coincidence but every generation
the winner has had the Call of Duty
marketing rights yeah because the 360
had it the whole generation PlayStation
had it uh the majority like the majority
of the of the generation yeah that's
because people don't realize the Call of
Duty marketing is just as powerful as
the game itself it is like b b bajar
whatever his name is badar but I think
it has plateaued you think it has
plateaued I don't because sales say that
that's not right you know plateaued with
the content they're about to have in
that service you think is plateaued we
canate must be a pony brother we can
debate all we want on the quality of
this and the quality of that but you
can't debate numbers and the numbers of
Call of Duty Call of Duty comes out in
November almost every year and out sells
every everything the entire year in one
month even even Vanguard did in 2021 and
they consider that a weak year every
year it out sells
everything and not even a whole month
like 20
days adct this years bet top selling
games of
2023 what was number like four Call of
Duty from last
year you know what's funny if you looked
at the the 360 like no the Xbox One the
sells from the all of Xbox and
Playstation Call of Duty was like five
or six of the games I remember that I
remember that chart I I I remember that
yeah it's it's like King said he said
all these exclusives don't add up to
that one like and not Xbox owns that one
yeah and not to mention you know we're
just looking at the marketing these
suckers gonna be in Game Pass day and
day I'm telling you
man they're going to plaster that
everywhere you get all you're going to
see that don't how do you think they get
they get ballsy enough to put like ads
for Xbox on war zone and when you log in
on Playstation it says something about
Xbox on war zone uh possibly man listen
because we've seen Xbox has been
advertising pretty good lately like you
said next year when these games brand
new Call of Duty is going to be in Game
Pass you know what would be the sting to
have to have
war zone make a reach map and it's on
Playstation too just fine it's on
Playstation but the fact that they gotta
play on an Xbox map
play yeah man uh so yeah so you say you
think it's Plateau you know like we
disagree with you um is it BB jar I
can't pronounce your name I'm sorry bro
yeah I mean I just think just you know
they have so much content coming if
you're stagnant if you're content with
your content absolutely it's you know
would just tap her off it plateau and
don't go any further but when you
constantly adding content just look at
Xbox road map and now include ABK in
that include Call of Duty in that on a
yearly basis we
saw when Xbox uh unlocked all of those
servers on those 360 Call of Duties and
all of a sudden you saw old Call of Duty
uh uh sales go up because that game is a
monster it's a beast and if XBox
advertises this right C because like
don't forget yes there's 50 million ps5s
out there about 25 million Xbox series
um but there's still a lot of people
that
haven't went to Next Generation yet
which of course is current generation
now
so people haven't went yet yeah yeah
yeah so but if you can advertise it
right and show yo the new Call of Duty
you get it in this service Game Pass as
long as well as every other Call of Duty
ever made for 10 to15 a month plus all
of these other
games some people are going to bite I'm
not saying everybody but some people
will
bite somebody B yeah
people people people don't
understand everything that's going
on you know it's just it's funny man
it's funny
yep all right so let's talk
about the PlayStation showcase uh you
know that just recently went down today
the Xbox uh showcase buddy oh Xbox
showcase I don't know man I'm just
looking at that last topic kind of the
preview yeah the Xbox partner preview so
we got 40 39
minutes and we gonna say yeah we just
say 20 seconds all right so let's let's
talk about the Xbox partners
preview
so let let me go
over let me go over the actual
announcements so obviously they showed
Allan Wake they showed looks great they
showed like a dragon infinite wealth uh
gets its own like Island resour I don't
know if it's a mini game or a full-blown
game they didn't really like I think
that that has to be a game inside of
that that game probably yeah and Co said
he didn't really like the way they
showed that cuz it it look like that's
the game yeah uh then we we finally saw
um you know Arc survival revealed
ascended which is like a remaster or
something a rem of the a remaster of the
apparently that's out right now yeah I
saw somebody put it in the chat earlier
then then we saw uh a Manor Lords gets a
PC release date and it's it is coming to
console eventually then we saw
RoboCop that you know what I think I
might pick that up bro
then we saw the still wakes the deep
that looks pretty good looks creepy as
hell dungeons of herberg uh gameplay
yeah yeah that's what I'm saying spirits
of the north
too is is that's one with the fox yeah I
thought that looked all right this one
really surprised me the
finals the finals look interesting that
that's the first person shooter yeah
that look that damn that did look good
tomorrow is a beta apparently coming
beta coming is it on consoles everything
yeah everything it looked pretty good it
did yeah that surprised me too iico will
not die in a fast-paced game with a Rog
like
element yeah so that what you say it's
it's that one where it kind of reminded
me of fury like more of a an estrom
metrical Fury so what do you think about
this man you know what was your opinion
on on this I thought it was fine um I
thought X box was transparency that's
the thing transparency say yo this this
is a Partners preview there's not going
to be any first party stuff it was 30
minutes long I I thought it was fine um
I thought having Metal Solid on there
really surprised me I wasn't expecting
that um of course we knew Alan Wick was
going to be there and it looked
incredible I literally like realized I
didn't pre-order and I after the show I
pre-ordered it because I forgot I didn't
pre-order it um the RoboCop you know
like we've seen a beta we've like like
PC people play the beta they said you
know that that the game was pretty good
so seeing RoboCop look pretty good you
know some of those other games look good
like you say was the game on the Water
The Deep or something the deep that game
looks good creepy atmosphere so I
thought it was fine I'm not saying it
was amazing but I give it like an eight
out of
10 the show was good it it it was the
content that didn't really drive me too
much and that's not that's not the show
or the content's problem you
know as a show it was a good show but as
a show for me it fell short you know for
the majority of this I didn't really
care about uh but I do know that you
know some of these games it's really
important for Microsoft to show more you
know Indies show more Pars in general
because that's how they maintain this
relationship um I like the pacing of the
show I like the the atmosphere of the
show it felt very like Nintendo Direct
to me uh besides like the thing talking
between the slides that happens in
Nintendo Direct uh I felt like this is
what they need to do like this format
keep this
up the problem is is people are
naturally going to want first party at
any show done by a console manufacturer
it doesn't matter if they have
expectations even if they they being
being transparent about it yeah but
people are still going to want the stuff
they bought console for you know it it's
it's always going to be in the back of
their head you know you can't you can't
knock
them but I don't blame people it's like
yo this is cool I want to see that
hellblade and you I think you will get
that you know I think the Video Game
Awards is coming up here soon they'll
probably have another developers direct
you think like next year probably
January yeah you know that I I do think
that you know this is the direction they
need to go uh with Game Pass
announcements this is the direction they
need to go with Indie Games coming to
their platform you know doing more
events like this I feel will make you
more appealing to work with Microsoft
and to work with Xbox this is what they
need to do uh but as far as like the
context I just wasn't feeling what was
shown and that's just a me problem
because I'm selfish I want what I want
but you know I did like what I saw on
like a dragon but for the most part I
don't care about Allan Wake I I did like
what I saw on um the finals but besides
that like they didn't really have a lot
for me you know it was it was definitely
you know it was exciting because I felt
like they found a good middle ground to
having these type of events I would have
just wanted more stuff that appeal to me
but that's just me well that's just you
okay that's fine um you know what I
disagree I thought the show was pretty
fun um nice little 30 minute show they
were transparent with you no first party
stuff is going to be here so people
still expecting first party stuff smack
itself you know that I mean listen if if
PlayStation had a show and said no first
party stuff just third party
stuff I would expect only third party
stuff um so yeah I thought it was uh I
thought it was a fine little show man
and this was like one of the first
things I've really seen where I'm really
starting to think that they are you know
not focusing on Game Pass entirely
anymore because this type of event two
years ago they would only let game this
and game passing this stuff uh
wholeheartedly and I saw Donna takaku
said said they only had one game pass
game U like like like one game that was
in Game Pass and that's that's exactly
what ale adct is saying in the past this
show would have been total uh they only
would have showed games where they had a
Game Pass deal um but no they no show us
games that's coming to the platform not
only in Game Pass Now The Game Pass
announcements are awesome don't get me
wrong but we want to see the games
that's not just on game you think about
it adct I will say this Allan Wake to
metal GE solid those games being at the
Xbox show is amazing because like you
mentioned they only used to show games
that was in Game Pass including big
third party games like a out riders or
something else so even though those two
titles I mentioned mle get solid three
and Allan Wake is not going to be in
Game Pass they showed up at a Xbox show
and love it you got to put yourself in
like Publishers and developers you know
uh in their position you know they want
to work with Xbox but I do think Xbox is
being very aggressive on making sure
games are in Game Pass and it's like
they wouldn't work with you but it had
to be certain conditions where they
would work with you if your game wasn't
in Game Pass up until now so you know
where were you going to you got to go
Nintendo or Playstation because it's
like either you give
up the right to where your game goes on
that platform or you mark it with
someone else and that's why I do feel
like this is the step in the right
direction for Xbox you know Game Pass is
still pushed but it's not the end all
Beall thing that's why I feel like that
that's that's good uh you know and I get
it people don't want to pay for stuff
they want everything in Game Pass and I
understand that because that's the kind
of mentality that Microsoft has put in a
lot of people for a long time but you
know people saying oh you know Game Pass
doesn't you know it hurts
sales for the most part I'm not going to
sit here and tell you 100% that this
that game pass didn't help hurt certain
game sales it did but for the most part
unless it was a first party those
companies got big bags put their game
Game Pass I know gaming didn't hurt adct
what
Starfield bro they stacking up on you
yeah let me grab them real quick I
apologize guys we just got into a good
conversation we got a $5 Super Chat from
Ray J uh R yeah remember D you have to
say stay on the scripted path yeah he's
making fun with somebody Spiderman yeah
stay on the scripted path like isn't an
open world game bro yeah I don't know
what they're going off with that5 super
from oxy guard um man these dudes
talking is man dirt you already know we
stand with you 100% WB
gtts all day every day every onx guard
appreciate you fam we got uh $2 Super
Chat come on I love you always see your
suit yeah I'm not wearing a Symbio suit
you POS I'm not Venom well first off
Venom's a little bit darker than you are
yes he's definitely darker than me yeah
$2 CH from gamer by choice when people
have no arguments they get personal
totally agree all the time bro I I see
it all the time $10 super from Dwayne
kovo Kito call him
Cito pronouncing it right but I feel
that Microsoft now has enough game
developers out that they can go full
force on Game Pass and crack out more
games now that they uh than they used to
it's a win win or both sides now yeah I
do I I think I think the amount of
content you're about to see from
Microsoft you you've never seen any
publisher ever
do you got to F out cweb uh Plateau
Plateau Game Pass gr 28 % in uh in 2022
and that was a horrible year they'll get
subscribers as long as the content is
quality and consistent that is a big
thing that people keep forgetting you
know you have to have the consistency of
of good to great games you can't have
bad games you know uh you know I hate to
use Metacritic but it's like you know
you get you pop you out some 80 85 90
pluses you pop you out like seven eight
of those a year it don't matter what the
other side's people going to go where
they're playing games
more 100% $2 TR from God Emperor suffa
King Allen wake is an L because it is an
epic exclusive PC I'll go where the
games are if you have to go to an epic
launch to play it I say B all means to
first off I'm Pro epic just gonna point
that out there you know uh not
necessarily Sofa King uh but PC Fanboys
have attacked me on all sides for years
David jaff in the chat what's up brother
what's up jaffy uh David we might have
to you
know let
me David jaffy jaffy my dude jaffy you
know I know there is a little bit of
friction there's a little bit of
friction w w w with with Cognito
past I'm pretty sure that's cleared up
now uh I would appreciate you coming and
and
uh join our presence on IOP this Sunday
you know I would like that I think
obviously there's the the cussing thing
you know we try to keep a PG you try to
keep a
PG but uh you know I think you would
give a a unique
perspective uh to this in specifically
show because of how close it is and
first off we
let's let's let's shout out
to people telling David jaffy the person
who worked with PlayStation for
years doesn't know anything about the
Connie
situation that makes no sense to me I
saw I saw some PlayStation Fans Say BS
come on man if there's anyone I'm G
believe on the matter it's going to be
jaffy Jeffy if you want a link tell me
you know I I'll let you pop through here
and you can give your he's he's eating
he's eating uh $2 subract from talk
sh no top sh sh top sh this is the first
party shows coming up at
BL yeah because they own blizzard so Bzz
it okay
um this is gonna be interesting he said
he got a big info dump an hour ago new
video oh a big info dump an hour ago
nice nice I can I'll read this bro while
you doing it Spartan 661 with def five
being an Xbox fan and seeing that third
party games are not as exciting as first
party games being released on Xbox
platforms is showing the
narrative um he say and seeing that
third party games are not as as exciting
it's showing the narrative I'm kind of
confused by that statement what you mean
maybe I'm AC a little slow all right
let's go to the next one yeah nintend
the taku with the five Xbox got 40 to 50
projects from first party and public ing
coming by 2028 anyone expecting Game
Pass not to grow is crazy yeah yeah I
think it's definitely going to grow even
more bro they're they're gonna have
consistent content in that service and
um it's going to keep on going 53
minutes and 40 and 20 seconds uh we're
moving straight to the last one because
uh I want um you know Jeffy to get his
bars across the thing that applies to
him that's why I said like I didn't
understand people trying to sit there
and say like David jaffy wouldn't have
an inside to this it's like but but when
David jaffy was talking about like
criticizing Xbox they they're all over
David jaffy like when David jaffy be
roasting field they love it yeah David
jaffy be speaking
facts but you know because he said he
had some info you know oh he said did
you send a link in the Discord I I sent
it to him on Twitter
oh so all
right we got some uh some bad news when
it when it comes to everything going on
with with PlayStation man they first off
they've had one hell of a year and not
in a good way it's been very you know
had all these people you know especially
in the industry you know you're pulling
out for the whole industry we've had so
many jobs lost you know it's crazy we've
had record breaking games making the
most money and then they'll turn right
around and lay off half they staff like
it's sad man it's sad you know I I call
it I call it quarter chasing you know
chasing quarter to quarter to make more
money than the the last and if you're
not going to make it off your own merits
and your own products you gonna make it
off cutting salaries and it's just it's
sad the way the industry well it's not
just this industry everyone does it and
you know it's it's pathetic it really is
you know people you know I can
understand if a game didn't do well but
a game will do well and they'll still
get
cut that's crazy
man so you know first off I want to
inform on the chat you know David jaffy
he he he tends to he tends to to to cuss
a little bit you know this is an IOP I'm
a little he has a little bit of a little
bit loose on here but I'm saying right
now the atct show is
PG-13 okay I can't help it I I can't ja
I asked jaffy to to to try to to try try
to behave but if he let stuff slip that
that's just jaffy like you know it it
took a while I was probably two years
old before I stopped cussing on the show
really yeah I cussed a lot on the show
and you know it's just it was just
something that Cog was very strong about
he's like look if we want to be if we
want to be
more of a family for show where you know
executives are willing to come on like
we got to be in that kind of thing so
here we go
PG13 starting
now what's up what's going on
Jeffy oh you muted yeah you're muted
this the place yeah I can hear you
what's up fellas what's going on man I
will do my best I heard what you were
saying I you know it's it's not it's
it's I was just raised this way
uh to talk like I mean I wasn't raised
intentionally to speak like this but my
mom cussed like a
sailor and it was never really a
negative thing and we would talk about
it it's like well why is this word worse
than this word you know and it just kind
of became my vocabulary so it's you know
people like Jeff he's always trying to
be so edgy I'm like dude I'm 52 number
one I I outgrew trying to be edgy in
junior high number two uh if I'm going
to try to edgy I ain't doing it by
saying oh he said a swear word so I just
you know it is what it is what's up
fellas how are you what you doing how
you doing man I'm good I'm kind of
annoyed I was on uh Colin Mor arti Last
Stand media today and my [__]
computer took a dump we were having a
great conversation for constellations it
was me and him and a couple other people
and then my C drive just got all messed
up so I got it I got it triaged until I
take my computer in tomorrow but I'm
kind of annoyed but other than that it's
going to be talking to you guys yeah
it's it's been a chaotic thing man you
know I felt like when it come to this
particular topic no one more qualified
to speak on this to you was in that play
yeah because you yes especially because
it come for you you was in that
PlayStation ecosystem for a long time
yeah I mean there are people who are
certainly more qualified but nobody's
talking but what I will tell you is
really been interesting is since
I uh started talking about this based on
the information I got
um I've had people reach out like I just
had a an individual reach out a
longtime uh Sony person uh and they just
just started info dumping their takes on
you know uh Jim Ryan and what happened
to Shawn leaden um Connie the whole
[__] hehw gang is is in there and I
said well is it okay if I talk about
this and he says yeah obviously don't
mention my name I said fine of course I
would never do that um but it's weird
because I you know I don't consider
myself a journalist at all I don't want
to be one I'm not chasing that Dragon
I'm very happy being the guy that just
sits on his butt and blabs about news
that other people break I'm totally okay
with that um but in this case I have
this data and it's like I don't know
what I do with it like it's one guy at
Sony and he reached out to me this new
guy the other the other has been
corroborated by multiple Sony people but
this is one guy
and I'm like well do I share it I mean
I'm not breaking it as news if I
contextualize it as hey here's a guy
from Sony Who would
know um here's what he said I assume the
fans would want to know that um but you
know maybe not maybe I shouldn't spill
it so I I I'm always struggling because
I don't really know where that wine
is yeah I feel you yeah you you
definitely man like when it comes to I
have a lot like when it comes to to the
that's what I'm looking for The Vow
Co-op situation I was told about that
like Sor the what the what there used to
be a co-op and a vow uh butow yeah U I
was told about that years ago okay when
it was originally and you know sometimes
you have like info that you like I can
really eat off of this I can really eat
off this so why would you not eat off of
it I mean what is because I was I was
asked not to say anything oh well that's
different yeah I would never I would
never spoil like I won't ever spoil a
game I knows in development uh or if
somebody tells me something and says you
can't use that oh yeah of course that's
totally different now this guy reached
out and said I said well can I use it he
goes yeah just don't don't say my name
but you know you can say that I longtime
Sony guy I'm like all right jaffy I've
literally hit people up that's told me
St but like yo IGN's talking about it
can I please make a video now yeah yeah
point it's it's it's fair game like but
I can't talk as I knew I had to talk at
as like reporting from right right
understood but anyway yeah I was annoyed
because a lot of you know I'm not
annoyed anymore I'm kind of getting used
to it um I'm getting better at not
reading the comments I'm getting better
at sort of removing myself from the
places where people do happen to talk
about things that I may be saying or
whatever um other than our own personal
Discord and if somebody reaches out to
me personally because it's just it's
it's it's nonsensical like you guys were
saying I mean it's like on you know I'm
sure you got I don't know if you you
guys seem very beloved but maybe you get
this as well but you know when one day
I'm the hero because I'm saying what
they want and the other day I'm the bad
guy because I'm saying something else
and I'm like you know what if that's the
kind of friend you are it's called a
fair weather friend I want nothing to do
with you don't don't worry about me
you're not gonna like what I say you
know I I my stuff is nowhere near as
Noble as this I'm not even trying to
paint it but it reminds me I just
tweeted the ACLU is actually saying
they're defending Trump because of this
gag order and and they hate Trump
they're like no one has done more to
destroy civil rights and and and and
First Amendment rights in America than
Trump this is what they were saying but
he also has a right to his
constitutional rights and he's American
citizen and this gag order is you know
so the idea of like just because you
disagree with somebody doesn't make them
the enemy you know they're just a lot of
us just sharing you know I have
PlayStation I have Xbox I have switch I
have PC I got a Ouya somewhere in the
closet over there I don't know where it
is um I just love games man so it's it's
weird but I don't know maybe they're
just trolling who the [__] knows what I
don't know
anyway yeah it's just when it comes down
to like this whole PlayStation Fiasco
stuff I just want your personal opinion
you know we've never really talked about
this you know going off of the the the
cony situation the Jim R situation yeah
uh you know it does look like maybe
their games is a service it some of them
might be in development hell we had uh
you know the uh the whole factions put
on Ice that one was defunded I can't
remember what that one was do you think
my deviation game yeah do you think that
g the games as a service model is is is
in Jeopardy you think all of PlayStation
is isting right now I think the entire
industry at the financial level of AAA
and console other than nintend I think
look I think Microsoft and
Sony uh are having in a lot of ways a
great year but I think they are
absolutely sailing into very uncharted
waters because on the Sony end you know
Shawn Laden made it clear and you can't
argue with the man's math it's math um
or as the British say maths idiots um
but um you know you can't argue with it
which is like this stuff you you know
forget Game Pass being sustainable you
can't keep spending more and more up to
$300 million on these games every now
and then maybe you'll be a GTA 6 and you
can but the vast majority even Sony and
Microsoft there's a point where it's
like okay this isn't working so there's
definitely some kind of uh you know uh
you know exploration of what that part
of the company's future looks like
because clearly they're not going to
stop making these kinds of games they're
wonderful Spider-Man 2.5 million in a
day great game I love that game um and
on this flip side I don't think a lot of
people look at what Jim Ryan was doing
at the beginning with games as a service
I think most people said yeah that makes
sense you know uh because that's kind of
what was working and what people didn't
realize including me was that it's just
more lightning in a bottle than simply
engineering a games as a service product
and being Off to the Races you may be
able to engineer one that is successful
enough to stay in business for a couple
years but the idea of the fortnite money
the Among Us lightning and a bottle um
you know that stuff is you can't
engineer that you know and and and and
and or if you can we need AI to tell us
how because no one knows the formula so
as all these games and service games
have come out and collapsed recently um
hell tomorrow they they're what what did
Xbox announced today the uh the what's
the game they have open Beta tomorrow
the the finals looks amazing great
destruction but you know if somebody
were to tell me that'll be gone in four
months I go man I believe it yeah not
because it doesn't look amazing but
because that's kind of the way it seems
to go for 90% of these dang things so
look what I did dang I said dang I
caught myself um so uh I guess what I
would say though is that Sony is I think
unless they have stuff they haven't
revealed that solves this
up against the wall when it comes to how
do we do games as a service and how do
we continue what we're brilliant at
moving forward with the economy not like
the world economy but like their the
video game thing getting more expensive
and no new Gamers coming in how do we
solve that Xbox's
problem is not as similar but it it's
like okay well we have to solve the
problem of how do we keep people from
churning from Game Pass and we're not
good at the AAA Sony stuff they're just
not they they they never have been as
good as Sony in my opinion at the
production value part that certain
Gamers seem to love uh but they're great
at other things and as we saw with
Starfield which I loved um you know that
shot Game Pass Subs through the roof in
September or whenever it was but then
the question is what's next right and I
don't know if they have the internal
management to be able to get to a
Cadence of genuinely
exciting uh even if it's small like a
high-fi rush uh content every month to
keep people from going okay well I got
game pass for Starfield two months in
I'm done like that's how I use the
Ubisoft Plus subscription model right
like I I think the crew by the way Crew
2 motorfest or whatever it's called is
the sh is great it's excellent It's a
Wonderful game um but I'm gonna get in
December or January uh Ubisoft Plus for
a month and play that a bunch Assassin's
Creed Avatar um and then cancel it you
know I I don't need to own those games
and so what's next I think that's
Microsoft's biggest problem and I know
they're trying to fill it by buying all
these Studios which is great which is
why they should go hire Connie Booth
because you need somebody in there uh
you know they haven't proven they have
the
management at a uh uh Xbox level to kind
of make these things really good in
coming out out frequently and I I just
don't think they they have that
experience I I would agree with you my
biggest concern with expanding the way
they have been is I don't feel like they
sit on the expansion they already have
to like really like dry out the Kinks
and make sure you know Communications
well you know really communicate to
every stud because if you're buying like
eight nine Studios and then you buy
another 10 like a year and a half later
did you really talk to the this the ones
you just bought before and I feel like
that's stuff that's how stuff like
rightall happened and it's just like I I
do personally feel like hopefully after
I'm sorry I'm sorry one sec one sec okay
after the ABK deal you know they'll go
into this bag and they'll really work on
you know making sure that the
communication is well between everyone
yeah I'm sorry about that I apologize
was stealing my Halloween Camp might
asked you a question David um yeah you
was just talking about
PlayStation they're having well not just
PlayStation but the gaming industry in
general with these triaa big budget
games you know yeah like you look at
kalista protocol I thought it was a
fantastic game $162 million budget game
didn't do so well and then you see the
studios like the The Glenn showfield
left and what's next he didn't leave I
think he pretty much was asked I don't
think he yeah yeah but let me ask you a
question we know the PlayStation does
single player game story driven their
games are absolutely great um what they
do in the future uh to maintain because
like you mentioned the games as the
service thing is a is a gamble we like
from your report I mean you know like
what you said earlier a lot of the
studios first party Studios they're not
feeling that what can they do at this
point well I think ultimately it's a
good thing for the medium because I I
think and I know a number of PlayStation
hardcore fans won't like this and there
something I can do about that you know
like it don't like it but I think
Nintendo does show the way I'm not
saying make Nintendo games like make
little kitty games Sony is tried that
before they've made some wonderful uh
all ages games like Puppeteer was
phenomenal Sack Boy Big Adventure on PS5
is excellent um but I mean more in terms
of Nintendo starts with the game play at
almost like in an abstract level like if
you ever hear the guys who made platoon
talk about where that came from it
didn't start with let's paint the
environment and let's be squids and all
it that all came after they knew they
had something mechanically fun and so to
me you know as much as I know a lot of
people including me like these big
budget you know cinematic games and
those are not going to go anywhere uh
there'll be less of them but those will
be there and there'll also be the double
A cinematic single player games and all
that end of the day though movies and TV
and books tell stories great um video
games do gameplay great and Nintendo
seems to be able to survive and sustain
and continually release beloved products
even though people who they're the same
they're not the same the IP is the same
but the gameplay is not the same um I
think Sony ultimately is going to need
to Pivot uh or any of these companies is
going to need to start going the bread
and butter of this industry of this
medium is interactivity and Sony has
been putting because it's been
incredibly lucrative and I get it
they've been putting so much Stu in the
production value and in The Flash and in
the narrative and all these other things
and it's not that the gameplay hasn't
been good but they need to be able to
stand on the game play first if they're
gonna want to continue because I think
what's happened is like leyen said
you're not seeing more console Gamers
coming into the ecosystem but the
budget's getting bigger yeah and so
where's the money gonna come from right
I think returnal is a great example I
don't know what returnal cost was to
make and I don't know if they made their
money back or whatever and I thought it
was a little you know tuned a little too
hard but whatever that's brilliant
freaking game though wonderful game and
that's a game where clearly gameplay
comes first it had a great cool story
amazing Graphics all that but it was
modular uh they did you know what is
this only fans I didn't pay for that uh
but I will oh now I'm paying for it baby
come on now come on now adct what's his
name snap but yeah but I mean I think
like returnal is a great examp I'm not
again I'm not I know H whatever Fanboys
I don't care I do it it's annoying but
it's like you know Steer your
ship into the realm or into the current
that the medium does best and I think
that's why Nintendo doesn't have the
world's best graphics at all but they're
still selling bucket loads so that's
what I would selling like crazy selling
like crazy yeah like all right um I'm
sorry like one more quick question cuz
this is this is the first time I ever
been on with you you ask whatever I
don't care and that's I guess that's why
you asked me to come on to talk right
yeah of course of course it's not like
you have a limit of
questions my chat gp4 you've reached
your allotted uh exactly no but you know
it it fascinates me you know I'm 47 I'm
a little bit younger than you but I've
been gaming a long time and I always
think about you know games from the 90s
and things like that I I thought about
like Super Mario War World on the Super
Nintendo fantastic game that game had
eight developers right then I want to
ask you God of War how many developers
created that game God of War
yes uh God of
War roughly internally we had probably
about 40 give or take a little more a
little less and then obviously we had uh
like the visual arts and Services Group
in San Diego helping us with the
cinematics and we had some Outsource
work being done uh with some writers and
stuff so all together there was probably
75 people but fulltime for the whole two
and a half years you were probably
looking at about 45 to 50 yeah so I
asked that question to say this um so
you think about that game right there
amazing game right uh 75 people two and
a half years of development now the
average AAA game is what 200 300 people
um more oh well depends which I mean
Ubisoft and and Rockstar go well beyond
that I mean the thous was like how did
it get get there like how did it I mean
I understand that the games are bigger
these open world games I know the
graphers are better things like that but
how did it get from a game like out of
water still holds up I know the graphics
isn't what it was back then now but the
game still holds up to yeah a triaa game
having 500 people developing it in like
a fiveyear time cycle like how did it
get there and how do we fix it I mean
well it's it's already being fixed it's
just the question of will the people
that currently Love the Way games have
been since PS3 came on the market with
the Cinematic stuff will they stick
around as the ship writes itself because
uh at least from my perspective of it it
you know I mean Sony Sony's weird
because Sony's to blame for it but at
the same time Sony has delivered such
loved content over the last couple of
decades that you can't really be mad at
them but part of their uh one of the
arrows in their quiver was production
value and graphics and motion capture
and real actors and all the things that
not only were instantly that you could
get walking through a Best Buy it's like
well that looks better than that it's
like yeah because they you know they
paid for that and the technology let
them do that so but that's where a
number of Gamers got trained with these
expectations that a game is a movie in
essence um in terms of production value
and cost and all that stuff and it just
kept working until I guess eventually
people at Sony said okay that that
variance between what we make and what
we spend used to be acceptable but now
even though we're
profitable we are taking these big risk
gambles 20030 million and we'll make it
huge profit at times but look at these
guys over here who only spent 30 million
to make fall guys or whatever and
they've you know so business people are
gonna look at it and go well this may
not be working anymore so I that's what
I think and that's what Sean was saying
ages ago and and I I just think um the
good news is if you aren't tied to
production value and you love games
there's no better time to be gaming than
right now I mean that the stuff is out
there at the AAA level the double A and
the Indie is amazing I mean you know a
lot of people poo poo it but like Dave
the diver is one of the best dang games
of the year um and people are like I
don't know what that is it's like yeah
because you only go to the PlayStation
Store the Xbox store and look at the
front page and you don't actually allow
yourself to eat at the whole Vegas
buffet you're just going right to the
Lobster absolutely um that was dumb but
you know I get the analy so that's
that's what I think that's what I think
yeah yeah I
feel I was told too that you know do you
think that marketing is one of the
things that really you know put millions
and millions and millions of dollars on
that or do you think like it's both
because to my mindset like both yeah
it's both but do you think that
marketing is mainly used for you know
returning IPS or do you think it's
something that's necessary to the degree
that's being marketed because you see
certain games not getting the type of
marketing the other games but they're
out selling the games with the Big
Marketing I think you would have
to have an awareness which I don't of
sort of what what is the what is the
return on investment for being in the
conversation like Spider-Man 2 did not
need to spend the money for a beautiful
3D billboard in Time Square but it was
gorgeous right people talked about it
they didn't need to spend the money to
somewhere I forget where they did it uh
Australia maybe hire an act like truck
you know but it was cool and I'm glad
they did it and that's fun but and I'm
not saying that's where most of their
cost goes anyway I'm just saying that
that gets them in the conversation and
clearly they think there's value there
but I I don't even know like you said
word of mouth and the internet is so
much more powerful now I mean where
games come from and where these Hits
come from the only thing here's the only
thing I would say and I'm just shooting
off the cuff here I don't really know
I'm not a marketing guy but my guess
would
be lightning in a bottle can happen
whether that's Five Nights at Freddy's
or whatever any of the stuff we've been
talking about um but you're really at
the mercy of the lightning and you don't
really know you can't really build a
business model around that whereas
marketing can at least come in and say
well we can't control the winds for your
sailing ship but we we can affect them
more than doing nothing and I think in
that I certainly know there's a great
value to it but
you know uh like there was never any
chance in hell Spider-Man 2 wasn't going
to sell well right uh but I don't know I
mean I don't I don't watch a lot of TV
anymore that's live that has commercials
I don't know if video games are spending
a lot of money on TV ads anymore and if
they even matter I mean who watches
commercials YouTube only sporting events
where you you'll see when I worked at
Dish Network I've said this a couple
times like they would let you send on
like these you know the these meetings
you because they try to educate you to
be a better uh you know agent and part
of the you know that was years ago that
was like 2019 17 18 they they were
already going away you know if you
wasn't back then you know The Walking
Dead uh commercial slots or you weren't
you know football commercial slots NBA
the Super Bowl like they weren't really
spending that right the money has
shifted way more towards YouTube Tik Tok
influencers
because they they have realized that
that is selling more actual like they
could they what our person called it
they called like Super Bowl stuff like
big commercial stuff they called it
shotgun marketing where you're shooting
into a giant crowd hoping you hit
someone and that isn't the marketing
that's being effective because when that
marketing was good is when the internet
was at its height I mean it's before the
internet was where it is now well yeah
and even even before streaming you had
people had too so even though you know
you would just skip all those
commercials uh or your DVR or whatever
you had and even then they were going
okay this is going away we have to
figure out how we're gonna you know deal
with this but uh yeah I mean it's it's
all changing and I think you know
Sony Sony will survive if Sony survives
Sony and Xbox and Nintendo none of these
companies deserve to live to fight
another day um you know if Sony goes
away and they won't after PS5 what a
amazing contribution to the Canon
they've made uh same with Xbox same with
Nintendo but you know they both of those
companies in my opinion are really uh
hopefully they have some real
Visionaries in those companies uh and I
do think Phil Spencer uh I love his
vision I don't like his management but I
love his vision for what he's bringing
to Xbox um so maybe he'll be able to
pull it off because you need that kind
of money to pull off that Vision but
maybe Sony's got more of a hey guys I
figured out how we could bring the
budgets down and still make these crazy
commercial games I mean that's that's
what they're gonna have to do if they
want to stay at that kind of you know
the kind of games they make primarily
but then the news I'm you know look my
understanding is Sony is uh very few
people anymore at Sony are thinking the
games is a service route that Ryan put
into play is actually working and is
gonna work is what I am hearing now I
don't know if that's true but I've heard
that from three or four people I you
know um and so in that what are they
gonna do I don't know but I think
there's real creative people there man I
mean there's Neil drugman Scott roie
Connie was up there but you know there's
the guys at Insomniac I mean look I
don't know what the budget was for
Spidey 2 but I know that it surprised
the heck out of me because I thought it
was just going to be more of the same
and they were able to take that formula
and really uh in my opinion add so much
more interesting stuff than just like
it's some it's a new code of paint they
really do really cool things their crowd
scenes in those games the pacing in
those games the narrative in those games
so maybe Insomniac has the secret sauce
uh assuming Spider-Man didn't cost 280
million if it did then I'll shut up
because I don't know I don't know what
they're going to do all right so uh I
don't know if you want to answer this
because I'm sure people hit you with the
God of War question all the time but we
got some answer whatever you guys want
someone was asking a question he said
question for jfy since you are a God of
War Creator in your opinion do you think
the 2018 God award deserve to win game
of the year over Red Dead 2 considering
it one more category I I think game of
the year is just you know it's a dumb
thing I like it I like to hear
individuals game of the year like that
because I you know but I've been on I've
said this before on a number of podcasts
I mean I've been on these nominating
committees when I was kind of working in
the industry and and and I've been you
know voting on them and all
this it's quite meaningless um not
everybody plays every game uh politics
play a point about to say a lot of I
want to work with this guy so I'm going
to tell him I voted for his game and I
did or I didn't um I'm not saying
they're totally useless but you know the
idea of this was I think the only way if
you really care about what the game of
the year was I I even know if that's
valid I think the best if you're really
only caring not about marketing but
truth you would say we're going to do a
top five games of what are we now 2023
so we would go back five years so we
would let history exist what holds up
what was just hype what was marketing
and so you're giving out those top five
games of the year five years after the
fact that's like the the the the honest
way to actually make that decision
because how many movies I mean you
really think Gandhi was a better movie
than ET you you really think Raiders of
Lost AR uh didn't have as much cultural
impact as Chariots of Fire are you
kidding me you think Annie Hall made
more sense to win the Oscar than Star
Wars which has created an entire
generation of Geeks that are you know
doing their own stuff now so my point is
ultimately the question is it's game of
the year's ultimately you can't really
talk about it like it's some real
important thing but that said I would
say God of War 2018 mean I loved it
thought it was phenomenal I rarely
finished games I finished it I thought
what Corey did and the team did was
amazing very clever didn't like Ragnarok
all that much thought it was wonderful
polished thought end completely dropped
the ball I couldn't finish it I was just
I thought the pacing was really slow
yeah um but red dead I haven't played I
know because people always tell me the
opening is too slow so I'm just like H
maybe I'll play it later but you know
look people in 2005 said Resident Evil 4
should have won game of the year but the
only reason it didn't is Capcom didn't
submit it and I'm like I'd buy that what
came the year in that year got a war
yeah right right so I mean we you know
did we get by on a technicality maybe
that's okay I mean I'm down I got the
trophy back there you know I'm
fine man I I I still God of War I man
that that that's still the goat to me
like right right I I loved 18 I thought
18 was better than Ragnarok cuz I
thought Ragnarok 18 was better than
Ragnarok Ragnarok was mild was worse
than than 18 well 18 had the advantage
of having this very cool clever rethink
of what it could be from a gameplay
standpoint to a character standpoint to
a tone standpoint but once you pull that
rabbit out of the Hat you need another
one because the game itself the momentto
moment is really good but it's just kind
of like yeah all right and they didn't
have another rabbit in my opinion I'm
sure you could speak like closing a
Trilogy is really hard doing it
effectively like I don't know I mean
it's just telling a story I assume they
had a plan I didn't finish it I heard
people were very disappointed with
Ragnarok itself like they were expecting
a big battle and it was just this kind
of like poof but I I I didn't get there
so I don't know yeah so you know I think
when it comes down to it you know I do
think
PlayStation um I'm just curious are they
pivoting completely away from the games
as a service because to me these games
still got to come out they spent too
much money like I'd be surprised if any
of them gets cancelled well I don't know
about that I mean I think certainly you
buy bunge you buy games as a service
right so I mean that that's happening uh
whatever what's their thing called
Marathon yeah unless it's just craps the
bed I don't think that's going anywhere
um factions I have heard what you guys
have heard no one has come to me I've
heard a few people say oh it's
officially cancelled people say oh it's
on pause I don't know
um but you you know I
mean it's uh I don't think games as a
service will ever be dead it's a viable
Market but do I think now Alexa stop do
I think now that these guys are seeing
the rubber meeting the road with a lot
of these service games collapsing I
think maybe now they're rethinking oh
should we really be doing 10 of these um
you know so I I I don't think they're
not going to have them I just don't
think maybe they're going to be as all
in as they were the question is what
does that mean does the money go back
and continue to spend 350 million on the
Last of Us Part three or do they figure
out you know uh something else and I
think there are there are things they
could do and I've talked about it before
I don't know if I'm right but there if I
was running that company uh or
Playstation I would try a couple of
things that they haven't tried yet but
we'll see what they do I got a question
for you Jeff you think Starfield gonna
get nominated for Game of the Year this
year um it should definitely be
nominated for writing uh or story or
whatever however they quantify that um
game of the
year
um I
mean certainly Xbox game of the year but
like overall um I loved it one of my
favorite games of the year and one of my
my favorite single player game
personally that I've ever played um but
as a
game it was great but it wasn't it
wasn't tears the kingdom re evolutionary
it wasn't Spider-Man even though the
story in Starfield is much better than
the story in Spider-Man the overall
package in Spider-Man I think Trump's
Starfield so it might but I I don't
think you'll see it up there I think
you're gonna see here's the kingdom and
uh um Spider-Man 2 and Dave the diver
and you may not see you may not see Dave
the diver but uh uh B Gate 3 of course
and there's like one other one people
keep floating but I'm forgetting it I'm
blanking maybe Mario Wonder but I don't
think Mario wonder is uh I like it uh
it's really great and there are moments
of just pure magic in it but I don't
played and go oh my God like when I
played Yoshi's Island for the first time
and that's not Nostalgia I wasn't a kid
I was like in my 20s I was like okay
this is brilliant but wonder I think has
moments of that but overall it's just a
really good solid Mario game so maybe
the Mario slot maybe that final slot is
going to go between Starfield and Mario
and we'll just see what happens I have
no
idea so we're going to go ahead and uh
be closing this out here don't want to
take too much of your time no I'm going
to run do you guys have anything else I
need to uh respond to anybody pay you uh
no not nothing for okay I don't want I
don't want to leave if people have paid
to ask me a question okay let me see
what he says about this one real quick
Dwayne with the $10 Super Chat let's be
honest here uh where do you guys see
PlayStation in the future because I
truly believe financially they would not
be able to continue much anymore at this
rate they're going I think Jeff uh Dave
kind of touched on that a little bit
that do need to restructure in some way
yeah I don't think anybody I don't think
we know they haven't announced it I
think there's a lot of plays that you
could run and say let's try this let's
try that let's try this but I think what
seems to be becoming very clear is
staying the course at least for the
number of games they make that are like
that is probably not going to be as
plentiful but then again I mean look at
look look I understand factions was
supposed to be this year but good Lord
Sony announced something
Spider-Man 2 is brilliant I love it but
could you put oh again here put
999999 at this point she's coming over
here just show feet adic adic um but
yeah I think at this point I you know
what is Sony coming out with I'm sure
they'll have a lot I'm not I'm not
saying they're not oh they're screwed
they have nothing that's what people
will take from The Narrative that's not
what I'm saying I'm just saying that it
is weird that you've got this number one
first party platform and we have no no
idea what is after Spider-Man 2 I mean
we know hell divers but you know I don't
think hell divers Wolverine we you think
Wolverine is coming 2025 proberbly I
think Wolverine is Christmas 2024 I
think it's launching with the PS Pro I'm
I'm making this [__] up I don't know but
I mean I but I think based on schedule
and based on how fast Insomniac seems to
work maybe you would get a Christmas Pro
with Wolverine and not package but I
mean with release time I think you're
going to get GTA which you're going to
want to play on the pro because
Microsoft has said we're not doing a
refresh so the best place to play GTA 6
which very well may come out next
Christmas is going to be on the pro if
you're talking consoles and then
obviously you're going to have Xbox with
all the the new Activision stuff and a
bunch of other stuff so I think the the
war next Christmas which is not even a
war the joy of next Christmas is GNA be
you're GNA have so many great games
coming at your butthole that I don't
think you're going to know what to do
with yourself yeah to but I appreciate
you coming com through here yeah thank
you guys thanks for having me I'm
serious though uh the invite is
definitely there for you guys just reach
out and say hey jaffy this is the Sunday
we'd want you to come on to talk about X
and this Sunday this Su so hit me up on
on a Discord give me other details like
when what time all that and uh let's
make it happen all right all right you
guys be safe well I'll see you soon
thanks for having me guys you too man
you have a good afterno great David
jaffy stop by the atct show man that was
fun that's my first time being on with
them man I've been in a uh I know you
have you know say first time I've ever
been on with them let me go ref finish
these super chats Spartan 661 with the
$2 Super Chat d The Narrative is Xbox
has great games again oh okay sorry bro
I'm a little slow but thank you yeah
absolutely they they do I'm a little
slow sorry and then shout out to God
Emperor s the king with five gifted chat
the gifts game put some put some logos
in the chat to settle
in there man yeah put put some some
Crest in the chat man appreciate the
five members he Haso five of you with
the whole the line emotes you have the
hold the line emote in that chat now I
expect to see that IOP this Sunday you
know D I'm gonna be real with you this
Sunday especially this stuff da David
jaffy putting out I don't know what we
gonna do with King I really don't
like can't wait King is already like
normally King like like put the laughing
emoji when we put links in our IOP chat
he made a like a voice chat and he's
like I told
you King is the man bro CZ he know like
he was on wbg a couple weeks ago and it
was a actually our biggest ever wbg bro
we yeah I saw that had like a thousand
live
view almost at 10K man so shout out to
King Dave man oh let me get this Super
Chat real quick for we head out $10
Super Chat from the angry therapist
great show guys dirt addict this was
fire I appreciate it man we tried we
tried to give you guys a good show every
week yeah we try to you know sometimes
uh uh we we we don't uh but in in my
eyes we do every week but that's just uh
so I'm gonna I don't know to send you
guys to see K be following these
channels and I have no clue who they are
hey man who the hell call me King Dave
oh my God black Baldhead guy with
beards jez cord with the 10 uh is that
pound I don't know man that's EUR that's
EUR 10 euro Super Chat buts you
ridiculous JZ hey jez what's up buddy
trying to I never been on a show with
jez either you know jez you gotta go on
dirt show jez yeah man you can swear we
you got to go on dirt on on dirt show
Jaz it' be funny man I'd like to see
that jez I'm looking at you probably
like what is this fan these these fan
these Xbox Fanboys over here where you
at jez I'm looking at you hey y'all I'm
leaving my channel in the chat check it
out got my dark man podcast tomorrow I'm
gonna have some fun gonna have a lot of
fun the Xbox drop some numbers you know
the stuff with PlayStation uh yeah I'm G
have a lot of fun tomorrow stop by guys
I don't know what this this HP podcast
248 is but Cog has followed them so I
assume they're good to some degree go
over there and drop a uh tell them
another Super Chat let me grab it real
quick $2 super from Hector de Macho Man
hit the like button you turkus that's
the homie right there doesn't sound
right unless you you read it it doesn't
sound right unless you say heck to the
Mau men with the two hit the like button
you turkeys your J mother watch you my
boy oh you know they they we we need you
to
play that game again death Loop yeah who
Am y'all sucker who him your ass come
over here boy definitely go over there
uh you know follow follow dirt Man
follow dirt dirt dir be putting in this
work even with jaffy coming in we still
didn't go past uh an really an hour and
a half yeah man great job cuz you know
the NBA season started last night but my
team plays tonight and I want to be in
front of the damn t Vision so thank you
brother all right so let me send you
guys over there I hope you guys uh I
don't know this dude so uh keep that in
mind you know I probably shouldn't send
you guys to him let me see let me see
who it is but I'm I'm willing to give
people chances okay I'm willing to give
people chances and we're going to give
this Ben the handsome dude a chance so
go over there tell tell him uh the atct
show Cent you Tom dirt and adct C you
and uh I hope you guys have a good day
we out
peace peace my girl says
peace